20-18 was a great year for horror movies
but horror fans have even more to look
forward to over the next couple of years
intriguing remakes sequels to Smash Hits
and awesome original projects from
beloved filmmakers are all making their
way to horror fans in 2019 2017 s happy
deathday was a surprise hit a slasher II
take on Groundhog Day the cleverly
milked its premise for scares and
featured a winning lead performance from
Jessica Roth the original film's ending
saw our heroines time loop finally
broken but director Christopher Landon
has teased that he left some important
details unanswered for the sequel Landon
will handle scripting duties in addition
to directing this time around with much
of the cast set to return Roth has
confirmed that the sequel will indeed
pick up right where the first film left
off comparing its aesthetic to the Back
to the Future series happy deathday to
you is expected to hit theaters on
February 14th 2019 the directing team of
Kevin Kolsch and Dennis wittmeyer
Wilhelm the upcoming remake of one of
Stephen King's scariest stories Pet
Sematary has a killer creative team
lined up with a script co-written by
David Kadena CH who wrote this year's
Suspiria Jason Clarke will star as the
beleaguered father Lewis Creed alongside
Amy Simons as his wife Rachel while John
Lithgow will play the Creed's neighbor
judge the film is set to spook audiences
on April 5th which gives you plenty of
time to rewatch the terrifying 1989
original the curse of La Llorona is an
upcoming flick based on a famous Mexican
urban legend surrounding the ghost of a
mysterious woman director Michael Chavez
makes his feature debut on the film and
early reviews are extremely positive a
recent screening at San Diego comic-con
reportedly brought down the house the
cast is headed up by Linda Cardellini
and Raymond proves a veteran actor who
made an indelible impression as the
psychotic Tuco Salamanca and Breaking
Bad smash off set in the 70s the film
follows Cardellini as a widowed social
worker who begins to turn up unsettling
similarities between her family's own
tragedy and that of a case she's
investigating it turns out that both of
them may have ties to the vengeful
ghosts that the movie is named after the
legend of La Llorona is well-known in
Mexican culture but it's all set to go
mainstream on April 19th 2019 2004 is
The Grudge based on the 2002 Japanese
film Chuang didn't exactly well critics
but audiences were scared out of their
shorts by the film's insanely creepy
imagery next year audiences will once
again have a chance to get spooked by
the vengeful ghosts in the upcoming
remake this revival holds significant
promise for one good reason the
involvement of writer director Nicolas
pêche whose 2016 debut feature eyes of
my mother was a masterclass in suspense
and atmosphere
John Cho and Lin Shaye have joined the
cast and Sam Raimi producing the film
through his ghost house Pictures imprint
has said that the new adaptation will
draw on the source material rather than
the 2004 version grudge is scheduled to
arrive on June 21st the conjuring
universe just can't seem to stop
expanding outwards as if the recently
released the nun and the newly announced
the Crooked Man wasn't enough a certain
supernaturally possessed porcelain doll
will be coming back for Annabelle 3 next
year
[Applause]
returning screenwriter Gary da Berman
will be taking over the directing reins
as well in his debut for the as-yet
untitled Annabel sequel the film will
see the return of the conjuring psychic
investigators ed and Lorraine Warren
played by Patrick Wilson and Vera
Farmiga B Annabel sequel will reach the
big screen on July 3rd from the moment
that 2017 s it ended speculation has
been running rampant about a sequel in
particular who would fill the roles of
the adult versions of the losers Club
well wonder no more since it chapter 2
has cast a bevy of excellent actors to
play the modern-day version of the
losers Club Jessica Chastain James
McAvoy and Bill Hader will all join the
cast while the extremely talented child
actors that anchored the first it will
appear in flashbacks and of course Bill
skarsgård will return as penny wise in
all of his terrifying glory considering
that it shocked everyone by virtue of
being one of the best horror films of
the decade it chapter 2 is one of the
most highly anticipated films of the
year in any genre but it's got a pretty
long wait the film is slated to hit
theaters on September 6th escape rooms
in which people pay to figure out how to
liberate themselves from seemingly
escape-proof places have become all the
rage in recent years so it's anybody's
guess what took Hollywood so long to
come up with a thriller based on the
claustrophobic premise but finally here
we are
the aptly titled escape room is coming
our way in 2019 the film brings together
six strangers who receive mysterious
invitations to participate in a hardcore
escape room which promises a $1,000,000
prize to anyone crafty enough to
complete its challenge as seen in the
harrowing trailer this is a room which
has ways of making sure nobody ever
leaves director Adam Rowe Battelle
responsible for insidious the last key
as well as the underrated the Taking of
Deborah Logan will be at the helm with a
cast headed up by Deborah Ann Woll
Taylor Russell and Logan Miller escape
room will make its debut
immediately after the new year on
January 4th 2017 split was a triumphant
return to form for M night Shyamalan
following years of questionable choices
and poor reviews
telling the story of Kevin Wendell Crum
a man with 24 distinct personalities the
film was a lean triumphant piece of
horror film making it also had the old
patented Shyamalan twist split revealed
itself at the end via a well-placed
Bruce Willis cameo as a stealth sequel
to Shyamalan mm hit unbreakable
mr. Hollis
speculation immediately started running
rampant that a third installment was
forthcoming and it didn't take Shyamalan
long to confirm the glass named for
samuel l.jackson villainous unbreakable
character would reach theaters in 2019
Jackson himself didn't realize there'd
be a need for him to reprise his role
until he saw split but as he told the
CinemaCon audience he's thrilled about
it for a specific reason it's about time
I got the title role of my own mother
movie the trailer features Sarah paulsen
as a psychiatrist specializing in
patients who think they're superheroes
and considering the super-powered
denizens of the glass universe
she's probably bitten off more than she
can chew it appears Jackson's mr. glass
will once again be pulling strings
manipulating Willis's David Dunn into a
confrontation with the Beast McAvoy also
returns as does splits anya taylor joy
glass premieres on january 18th
ever since MGM quietly resurrected the
long defunct Orion Pictures imprint in
2014 the studio has struggled to find an
identity once responsible for classics
such as First Blood Bill & Ted's
Excellent Adventure and Silence of the
Lambs
Orion has spent the last four years
cranking out films which have gone
largely unnoticed by the general public
but a couple of exceptions like the town
that dreaded sundown and James Gunn's
2017 thriller the Belko experiments
those films were fairly well received
and enjoyed relatively high profiles and
they had something else in common
they're among the studio's only horror
pictures making up their post-2014
output perhaps MGM execs finally noticed
the extreme profitability of the genre
in recent years because Orion's first
effort of 2019 The Prodigy looked
suitably terrifying Nicholas McCarthy
will direct the film which looks to put
a new spin on the creepy child sub-genre
plot details at then but the trailer
looks atmospheric as all get-out and the
film boasts a pretty stellar cast we may
have an omen for a new generation on her
hands Fox Studios New Mutants part of
its marvel x-men universe has had a
troubled history originally scheduled
for release in April 2018 who was first
pushed back 10 months to February 29th
and then an additional six months to
August after a series of test screenings
didn't produce the reaction the studio
had hoped for audiences responded well
to the film but Fox had been shooting
for stellar scores and decided to take
extra time to make new Butte ins as good
as it could be since it will be the
first true horror film of the x-men
franchise this seems like a reasonable
approach the trailer released ahead of
the film's initial release date promised
a claustrophobic creepy good time but
this is a film in which tone will be
everything the recent deal between Fox
and Disney which will likely see the
x-men Fantastic Four and Deadpool end up
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe at some
point doesn't seem to have affected
Fox's plans for New Mutants the film
will appear in theaters to soon for any
cross-pollination to take place even if
any was planned despite rumors that the
long delay and Disney deal meant the
project might be shelved
it's been confirmed that new mutants
will arrive in theaters on August 2nd
followed may sound a bit familiar at
first it's part of the new breed of
found-footage flick known as screen life
in which all the action takes place
within the confines of computer and
smartphone screens if it seems like a
cheap gimmick consider that the well
received unfriended and its sequel
established the viability of the device
as an effective storytelling tool and
the John Cho LED searching did even
better critically and despite its
similarly techie title followed doesn't
appear to be simply capitalizing on this
trend but expanding on it the film stars
Matthew Solomon as a controversial
blogger who specializes in the sick and
twisted who must up the ante after a
benefactor promises a huge influx of
cash if he can pump up his subscriber
base by Halloween he plans to get a
subscriber bump by live-streaming his
stay in a haunted hotel which of course
does not go according to plan aside from
its unfriended meets 1408 premise the
film innovates by periodically breaking
the immersion to take on the first
person viewpoint of whoever is watching
the video clips adding to the growing
mystery of just what exactly is going on
here followed made its debut in 2018 at
the Burbank International Film Festival
where it took home the prize for best
horror feature making it one of the more
intriguing horror films to watch once an
official release date gets announced
2017 s 47 meters town
a tense nail-biter of a deep-sea
thriller featuring Mandy Moore and
claire Holt as sisters who get way more
than they bargained for on a shark
watching adventure in Mexico the
modestly budgeted production turned a
respectable profit so in 2019
entertainment studios will bring us 47
meters down the next chapter the sequel
will feature an all-new group of
characters in a Brazilian locale who run
into some serious shark based problems
while searching for a lost underground
city